よろしくお願いします
えーと 今日のテーマは何のために稼ぐのかというテーマで
一応まあ仕事やら財産やらね
そういうことについてまあいくらか話して挙げてみたいと思います
で あの 聞こえないね 財産に対して
まあ一般的にはまあ欲が良くないとかね
まあいろいろなことを聞いておられると思いますから
まあこれもやっぱり明確に勉強した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で これ 仏教というのは一概に極端的にあの喋ってるわけじゃなくて
ちゃんと物事を厳密に具体的に論理的に分析した上で
真理を発見した上で語られています
だからお釈迦様におっしゃられたものっていうのは
全く誰にでもいまだにそうではないと違いますということは
全く言うことは難しいんです
言うのはいいんで言えますけどね
ちゃんと根拠があって言うのは難しいんです
そういうことで あの順番であのあらゆるテーマに分けて分析して話します
まず この業ということで
あの業が命を支える 生きてる上で我々も生かしているエネルギーっていうのは
仏教では業と呼ぶんですね
これが ちょっとわかりにくい
ちょっとではなくても
かなりこの機能働きはまあ理解しにくいんですよ
行為と結果という風な話なんですけど
まあそちらにもまあ結果はいろいろあるんだから
ただ 窓ガラスに石を投げたら窓ガラスは割れるとかね
そういうふうな行為と結果っていうのはすごい明白で
分析も説明もできます
しかし 必ずしも行為がその瞬間で結果出すということでもありません
例えば電気 電力を作ろうとダムを作って
そこで水を蓄えておく
だから ダムに水が蓄えたら
すぐ即座に電気が生まれてくるっていうことじゃないんです
やっぱりタービンに水を放出した時に限って電力が現れてきます
そこまではまあ一応原因は作ってます
水を溜まって浮いたという
でも結果は後なんですね
すぐ即座ではないです
だからこのエネルギーっていうのは
なんかポテンシャルとして
あるということをね あのダムに行ってみたら
何のエネルギーも見えませんよ
ボートで遊ぶこともできるし
ほとんどもう波も立たない
ただもう溜まった水だから
川の方が激しいんですけどね
ダム作ったらそこら辺はただ湖になるだけでね
何のこともないんですよ
でもそちらにはなんかエネルギーは蓄えていますよ
だから水をそこで放出したら
かなり力で巨大なタービンを回して
すごいエネルギーを電気エネルギーを出してくれるんですよ
だから このポテンシャルとして
我々の体の中で 心の中でえらいエネルギー溜まってるんだけど
それわかるわけないんですよ
ポテンシャルとして溜まってるんだから
ないと等しいように感じちゃうんですよ
でも結果が出そうとすると
なんとなく感じるんです
まあ人々でもなんかいろんなことをやってる
やってる時 何かやる行う前に
なんとなくそうせざるを得ないような衝動がなんか絡んで空回って回ってるんですよ
悪いことであろうが いいことであろうが
まあなんかそれは行う前に
なんとなくこのエネルギーが出てきて
まあ回転する その時だけ感じますけど
もう遅いんですよ もう瞬時に結果出すんだからね
そういうことで このそれが仏教ではカンマというんですね
で カンマッサカーマナワサッターカンマダーヤーダ
カンマヨーニカンマバンドゥカンムパティサラナ
えーと カンマンサッティヴィパッティヤリダンヒーナッパニータターヤっていうのは
このあるスバッというある人がおそらく若者だと思いますけど
お釈迦様にもこの世の中にも差別
区別とは一体何なのかと
人々は長寿の人がいて
短命な人がいる 美しい人がいて
醜い人がいる 病弱な人がいて
すごい健康な人がいると
それで上の高貴なカーストで生まれる人がいて
すごい低いカーストに生まれて苦労している人々もいるし
豊かな人がいて ものすごい貧乏な人もいるんだと
何やこれと バラモン人だったらそういうふうに神様が作ったんだそうと信仰すればいいのに
この人はそう思ってなかったんで
なんかお釈迦様に聞くんですね
お釈迦様は言うのは これはカンマだよと
業だよと で 業の場合はだからお釈迦様はマナーというのは若者よということで
で 若者よ カンマッサカ
カンマッサカ 自分のものと言えるのは
自分のものっていうのは自分から決して離れないもの
一体になっているもの
それが業であると まあ肉体のことだけ考えてみると
まあ目やら耳やらね これは自分のもので
こちらに忘れて置き忘れるわけはありませんね
カバンとか他のものだったら置き忘れちゃうんですよ
これはそれほど自分のものじゃないんです
肉体の場合は 目やら耳やら鼻やらね
一度でも置き忘れたことはないでしょうね
どこへ行っても持っていくんですよ
しかし 肉体は本当は自分のものじゃないんですよ
例えば一部が故障しちゃうと
何のことなくそこはもう切って捨てちゃうでしょうね
自分のものだったらそれはできないはずなんです
体のいろいろところがね
悪くなると それは摘出するんですよ
し それ全部できなくなるんですよ
一部切ってしまえば その分自分の一部がなくなるんだからね
だから足一本なくなっても
両足もなくなっても 両手なくなっても
別に自分は自分なんですね
何かなくなったわけじゃなくて
ただ物質物体が一部なくなっただけで
だからそのたとえ それほどいいたとえじゃないんだけど
一応我々に分かりやすく言えば
肉体だけ考えちゃうと
目やら耳やら鼻やらね
そういうものは自分のもので忘れることはありません
別に負担ではありません
どこへ行っても持っていくんです
業っていうエネルギーは個性が自分のものなんですよ
それは肉体じゃなくて心の中にあるんですね
それは自分のものというのは業であると
で 我々は相続するのは業であると
いわゆる相続っていうのは
もうもう まあ自分自身なんですけど
自分がどこへ生まれ変わっても
犬になろうか 猫になろうか
鳥になろうか 死んでからね
幽霊になろうが関係ないんですよ
業は相続するんですね
業というエネルギーは
離れません どうしても
で それから人の生まれ
生まれっていうのは面白いことで
このパーリ語ではようにと言うんですね
で  ようにっていうのは女性の体から生まれるんだから
そういうところを表す単語なんですけど
まあ私たち知ってる生命の中で
生命がどこから生まれたかの生まれたのかということによって
何者かとわかるでしょうね
雌犬の体から生まれたら犬であって
猫の体から生まれたら猫であって変わりませんね
別なものが生まれるわけじゃないんですね
そういうことで 私たちは何ものとして生まれているんでしょうか
ということは 業が決めるんです
いわゆる業が生むんですよ
生命を 業って面白いことで
だからたまたまある一定の時間で我々は人間にいるだけ
人間として我々を生んだのは業なんです
それで親族 自分のもので言えばね
まあ親族っていうのはよく頼りになるとかね
まあいろいろ親族の中で我々楽しく生きてますからね
親族として何があったら助けて助けてくれるものとかね
言えばそれも自分の心にある業であって
あの自分のよりどころでもあります
人に頼んでも他人に頼んでもどうにもなりませんよ
例えば病気になったら
お母さん 私の病気早く治してちょうだいと言っても
お母さんにはどうすることもできません
その人の業の力で病気が治るんですよ
病気が治らないで死んでしまったら
それもその人の業の力なんですね
だから このよりどころにするのは業なんですよ
で 業が生命を区別する
生命の区別は業によって成り立つものなんですね
だから二人とも同じ人間はいません
生命もそうなんですよ
一匹一匹違うんですよ
同一っていうのはありえないんです
すべての生命は互いに違うんです
その区別も業の働きなんです
まあわかりやすく言えば
この他宗教で神という概念ですね
仏教では業と言っているのは
で 違うところは 業っていうのは自分が行うことなんだ
自分がやっていることなんですよ
人が人殺ししても 私は刑務所に行くわけないでしょうに
だからこの神といえば他人ですよ
全くも 神の働き 全部こちらにまとめているんです
神の仕事は まとめているんだけど
神という他人が 第三者が人を上下に区別すると
優れた人と卑しい人にするんだそうというと
なんか道徳的に問題あるんでしょうに
なんで一人に人が障害者で
人の人が健常者で作るんでしょうかと
これちょっとおかしいし
道徳的には成り立たないんですよ
だからどう見ても仏教はそういう第三者によってすべて起きているのという無責任
それ無責任感ですね 私には関係ないんだと
私には責任がありませんと
すべて第三者たる力によって起きているものであるっていうのはね
で それが理屈通らないんですね
その代わりにお釈迦様は
では何だと これなんで人間でありながら区別はある
動物でありながら区別がある
幸福な人も不幸な人もある
その区別はどのように現れるものかというのこのあるエネルギーを発見したんですね
心という心の中にある業という働きがね
それはまあ業ということなんですね
それで神と違うところ
よく覚えてほしいのは
業が私自身がやることだから
人に文句を言っても意味がないんです
だからポテンシャルになったらわけもわからない
例えばすごい過去で悪いことをしたら
それがポテンシャルになっている
だからもう感じないんですよ
過去ですごいいいことをしたならば
それも今の心にポテンシャルとしてなっている
ポテンシャルというのは機能しないんですよ
百メートル上に石一個を持っていっても
別に何も重さも何もない
何の変哲もないんですよ
しかしそれを落とすとかなり力になるんです
怪我する可能性もあります
百メートルから落ちちゃうと
もう当然怪我しますよ
体に当たったら大変ですよ
でも百メートル上に置いたら何のこともない
もう だからポテンシャルとしては全然わからない
それが何て言いますか
エネルギーは このリリースというか
何でしたっけ え？放出
放出するときで問題なんです
だから 私個人がいろんな行為をすると
その行為が全部もうポテンシャルになってなっていく
もう何のこともない もう忘れちゃいます
感じない でも場があったら放出する
それは避けられません
そういうことで 人間っていうのは本当にわかってるんだったらね
自分が事故を起こしたならば
それは自分の過去の行いだろうとわかったら
すごく別に納得いけるでしょ
アメリカで船で若い若者がね
高校生たちがね まあ突然事故を起こして死んじゃうとかって
私はそれは業ですよと言ったところで怒られるんですね
それは業は業ですよ だからその子供たちは過去世で何かした業の結果で短命になったんですよ
それに腹が立ったっても
それ自体が邪見であって
自分を戒めることはできなくなるし
だからこんなのは危ないんだから
やばいんだからね ずっともう落ち着く
何て言いますか 進む身を控えて行動しなくちゃいけないということになるのに
わからないんですよ そこで業の仕事内容
いくらか言ったんですけど
また説明します 生 生まれを決めるんです
人間か畜生か神霊か神か
誰かになるということは業がするんです
だから業が自分で作るんだから
自分が人間で生まれ変わりたければ
それなりのエネルギーを作らなくちゃいかない
神になりたければ それなりのエネルギーは自分が作らなくちゃいけないんです
一旦作っておけば 自動的にそのその結果は出てくるんです
それから その生命の上下関係
同じ人間に生まれてもまるっきり互い違いですよ
立派な人もいて 立派でない人もいて
そういうのは業がやっちゃうんですね
それから性別 それから寿命
これ本当に面白いことを
生命の寿命というのは決まることできないんですよ
この生物学的にいろいろ言ってはいますけど
それはもう一応あの何人かチェックして
もうもう割ってみて ジェネラルというか
何て言いますか 普遍的に
まあこれぐらいだろうと言うんであって
人間百年ぐらいだろうと
でも必ずしもちょうど百年で死ぬってことはないでしょうに
ちょうど百年経って零秒になったところで死んじゃったっていうことはないんですよ
だから まあ科学的に生命の寿命が言えるならば
そういうふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
それが言えないんですよ
時々すごい長生きする猫たちとかいるでしょうに
特に人間に飼われると
まあそれなりに  丁寧に飼っておくと寿命は長生き長くなるんですよ
なぜならば 野生でいるといろんな悪いことをしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで丁寧に飼ってもらっちゃうと
何も悪いことをしないで
ただただご飯を食って寝るだけの人生になるんですね
そういうことで 自分の持ってもらった寿命がね
結構機能する それで野生でいると
もう喧嘩しなくちゃいけないわ
もう狩りをしなくちゃいかないわ
まあそういう それは悪行為なんです
それで寿命はもう早く終わってしまうという
だからこの寿命っていうのは業が決めるんですよ
ちゃんと業が決めた寿命でちゃんと零秒になったところで死ぬんですよ
これは一秒も延びないんですよ
だから我々は今何時何分何秒に死ぬかっていうことを
我々の心にあるポテンシャルは知ってます
まあ知ってるっておかしいんだけど
そちらでは決まっています
その瞬間で死にますよ
これはもう絶対避けられません
もう命の法則だから 電気が消えたらもう光がなくなるっていうことだから
それから死の時期とその方法も業の仕事なんです
どんな風に死ぬか どんなところで死ぬか
一応業はそういうところを管理するんです
生きている時の管理 それから生きている間の管理も業がやってますよ
例えば頭良い子で生まれても
業で業から見れば立派な大学出て
知事になってそういう生き方は決まってない場合は
試験受ける時はなんとかやっちゃって
もうもう拡大しますよ
いくら踏ん張ってもできないんですよ
頭が悪いってわけじゃないんです
すごい微妙なんです だから
この障害あるかないかとかね
それから美しいかないかとかね
で 健康でいるかないかとか
それから我々の肉体の体力まで
業の仕事内容なんです
それだけじゃないんです
この生きるために必要なこの需要品をね
供給するのも業なんですよ
どんな服着るのか どんなご飯食べるのか
どんな家に住むのかどうかね
どんな環境にいるのかどうか
どれぐらい人々と付き合うのかと
業によって決まっています
性格の構成 我々の性格も基本的には生まれ
そのある一個の生まれ作ると
その生まれではどんな性格でいるべきかということも
業で決まってしまうんですよ
性格の基本的なプログラムと才能
能力なども業で一応作るんです
で 難しいが 努力によって性格が変えられる
難しいんですよ もう基本的にできてるんだからね
それ理性と理解があるならば
性格を変えることは簡単ですが
そうでない場合は一時的なものでしょうと
というのは この仏教 すごく智慧と理性ともう知識っていうのをすごく褒め称えています
なぜかというと この理解能力あれば
理性があれば かなり物事は自由自在に管理できるんですよ
あんな手に負えない業さえも生きることはできるんです
必要な理性 知識 智慧 物事を正しく判断できる能力
それだったら全くつかみどころない業っていうのは実感もない
なのに変えることはできます
それってまた不思議なことじゃないんですよ
自然法則さえも我々人間に好きなように変えるっていうことは
人間の知識でやってるでしょうね
科学っていうのはそういうものでしょ
科学発展というものは
人間の知識で変えるはずもないものは変えてしまうんです
しかし 法則乗り越えられません
人間にはそれは空を飛べないはずなんです
どう踏ん張っても しかし
知識のある人々は人間
空を飛べるようにするんです
それで私たちは今 飛行機で空を飛んでいるんだからといって
法則 宇宙の法則を変えたわけじゃないんです
遠力の法則やら何一つも変えてないんですよ
そのまんま しかし 頭を使っているんです
その法則の中で 同じく業の法則も変えることはできません
できませんが 理性あれば見事に操ることはできます
だから この性格なんか変えるっていうことは皆さんは知っていると思いますけど
そう簡単じゃないんですよ
もし理性があって理解能力があるんだったら
もう変えられます で そうでない場合は
あまりにも強引にしつこく言われると大人しくしようと頑張るんですよ
でも その言う人がなくなっちゃうと
また元に戻しちゃうんです
あるいはあまりにも自分にものすごい激しく
これからはこういうことをやりませんよとはっきり決めて
すごいきつい気持ちでいると
性格は微妙に変わるんだけど
あのエネルギーが弱くなるとまたドーンと元に戻るんですよ
だからまあ理性があったら
例えばこの なんていいます
ダイエットするそうと
ただ単に欲でやめそうと決めても
あのエネルギーがある時はダイエットできるんだけど
エネルギーが消えてしまったところでまた元に戻ってしまうんですよ
そうではなくて よく理解しておけば
食べ過ぎは体にも悪いし
もう情けないし 性格的にも良くないし
まあそれよりはまあ適適量を食べているのはまあ正しいではないかと
こういうこういう食べ物はもう美味しく見えるんだけど
本当は内容は体に良くないんだそうとよくわかるとすっごく簡単ですよ
そういうことで 理性っていうのは大事
必要になるんです  コンピューターのことをご存知の方々にとってはいい例えがあるんですよ
あの業っていうのは WINDOWS XP みたいなもんで
基本的な OS なんで それがないとパソコンは動かないんですよ
ただの代物でもうゴミのひとくくりなんですよ
しかし OS 入れちゃうと
まあこれから仕事をできる状態になる
できる状態だけ しかし
何をするのかということは
入れるプログラムによります
だから OS もいろいろでしょうに
今はほとんど統一されちゃって
もうほとんど 2つぐらいになってますけど
いくつかありますね UNIX
やらなんとかなんとかとかいろいろ
例えば UNIX で OS でコンピューターを使う場合は
決して WINDOWS XP
とは違いますね やはりUNIXを使う人々は
まあ例えばLinuxというもの
プログラムありますね
そういうのを使う人々は
何かそちらの長所を見てね
例えばウイルス入りにくいやらと攻撃しにくいとかね
そういうところを考えて
あるいは安いとかね あのオープンコードですから
まあ好きに自分の好きなようにコンピューター変えられますとかね
いうことで使ったりするんだけど
使い方は違うんですよ
そのような感じですよ
業っていうのは 本当は気にしなくてもいい
我々はもうワード作ったり使ったりする
これがなんとかプログラムでしたっけ？何でしたっけ？パワーポイント使ったりする
私たちはパワーポイントどうやって動かするのかしか全然知らない
しかし パワーポイントは WINDOWS というプログラムなければ全くもう機能しない
そこで WINDOWS でまるっきり気づくことなくパワーポイントを使っています
だから 私たちもいろいろ勉強したり
いろんなね 能力を身につけたりして
それはちゃんと知ってますよ
音楽の勉強で訓練したんだから
音楽できるぞと 音楽で食べていられるぞとか自慢はするんだけど
その音楽能力っていうのは
業という OS の上に成り立ってますよ
だから 業がその人を豊かにしてやるぞというプログラムがあるならば
音楽によって豊かになる
苦労させるぞという OS だったら
音楽やろうがエンジニアになってやろうが関係なく苦労することになるんです
でも その OS には気づかないんです
それから 善しからしから業は絶大で
ものすごいものなんですよ
幸福は業の働き 自分の人生に対していろいろと不満はあるかもしれませんが
業が自分なのです 私たちはどんな人間でもいっぱい不満持ってますよ
もうちょっと顔が小さく小さい方がいいんじゃないかとかね
あと 3センチ背が伸びた方が良かったんじゃないかとかね
いろいろありますよ で
30代でも歯がもうもう壊れてしまう人々もいるしね
まあせいぜい 60年まででももった方がいい
あった方がいいんじゃないかとかね
いろいろもう不安があるんだけど
しょうがないんです 業が自分なんです
ただ まあ自覚ないだけ
自覚があったらすっごく落ち着くんです
失敗はしたくない 嫌な性格を変えたいと思う気持ちはあるが
理性 知恵と努力がなければ無駄に等しい
人間 いろんな希望があるんですよ
失敗なんかをしたくないとかね
成功してやるぞとか そんなことを欲張って希望期待しても全然うまくいかない
だから仏教は欲望 希望と願望は危ないんだから捨てろと
ただ苦しいだけだよと
欲望があってもあっても
そううまくいくわけじゃないんです
もしうまく行って欲しければ
たとえ貧困の家系で生まれても
貧困は嫌だと思ったならば
理性と努力と まあ知恵っていうのはインスピレーションのようなものなんですね
そういうものを使うと
あの業が変わるんですよ
でないと変わらない だから欲望希望じゃなくて
人間理性働かすんですよ
そうすると人生は自分の好きなように変えることができます
欲 怒り 高慢 見栄などの感情で夢を見て期待希望するが
結果は業が決める 人間は感情でね
見栄やら嫉妬やら高慢やら
いろんな感情でああなりたい
こうなりたい あしたい
こうしたいと思うんだけど
一つも希望通りにはいかない
業という OS が決まっている通りに行くんです
だから感情 欲望 希望 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみっていうのは
人間にとっては邪魔であって
全然助けにはなりません
それで問題は 今日は稼ぎの問題だからね
業があるのになぜ仕事をするということ？業っていうのはそんなに偉くて
もう寿命まで死ぬ瞬間と死ぬ方法まで業が決めるんだったらね
何を食べるかっていうことも業が決めるんだから
どんな服を着るのか どんな家に住むのか
すべて業ですよ 業が決めるんです
だったら仕事する必要ないでしょうに
考えれば ないんだけど
それも業が決まってるんです
仕事をしろと 働いて必需品を得る生まれ
業がすべてを揃ってくれる生まれもあるのです
いろんな生まれがあるんですよ
働いて 自分で働いて必需品を揃えなさいというプログラムで
その場合は働く能力は与えてくれる
働かなくてもいい すべてオートで自動的に揃えてあげるぞという生まれもあります
その場合は働かなくて
例えば神々っていうのはそういう存在なんですね
仏教でいう神々っていうのは
あの 仕事はしない ご飯も作りません
服も買ったりしない 天国ではデパートはありません
ただ 生まれた瞬間で完全な体で着るものやアクセサリーは全部ついてるんです
体に その神が何を食べて食べるのかっていうこともそれで決まっていて
その瞬間に自分にそれあるんです
その場合は仕事をしなくていいんです
それから次の悪業の場合は
ほとんど必需品を与えないで
命だけ維持する生まれもあります
例えば業は悪業だったら
業っていうのは言い忘れたんですけど
良い行為も悪い行為もまとめて業と言うんですよ
だから人は幸福になると
それは業 不幸になるとそれも業
ですから善行 悪業と言わなくちゃいけないんです
それで悪業を行ったら
それもエネルギーに ポテンシャルになる
それで悪業によってどうなるのかというと
どこかに生まれ変わる
生まれ変わったら この業がその人の寿命をずっと維持してやるんです
死なせません しかし 必需品
必需品を与えてくれない
頑張っても頑張ってもないんです
必需品がないと死にかけているんですよ
ものすごい苦しいんです
死にかけてはいるんだけど
死なないんです 死なすかないかっていうのは
業が決めるんだから で
あの この地獄とかね 餓鬼道とか
は そういう生命なんですね
ものすごい苦しいんですけど
死なないんです だから必要なものがないということが苦しみなんですよ
食べたくて食べたくて
お腹が空いて ものすごい衝動があるんですよ
食べたいという でも何一つも食べるものは目に入らない
並の苦しみじゃないんですよ
そういう風に五感にすごい激しい苦しみが与えるんで
生まれるんで与えるんじゃなくて
業はそんな悪いことしない
業がただ悪業 もう悪いところにもう幸せを作っちゃうんです
そうすると寿命も決まってくるんです
それだけ 物は得る もらうエネルギーはないんです
もともとないんだからしょうがないんです
だから誰にも文句を言うことはできない
ただ苦しいだけの生き方になるんです
業により肉体をこれで肉体を持つ生命になると
その体は物質なので 物質の法則にも管理されます
これは我々とこの動物の世界の問題なんですよ
肉体を持ってるんですね
肉体っていうのは物質ですよ
外から最初の肉体の微妙なところは業を作るんです
今も業によって肉体が構成されてますよ
では ほんの一部で 外の世界からの物質を入れて作らなくちゃいけないんです
そうなると この外から入れなくちゃいけない物質を入れるために仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで仕事をできる能力は
業はつけてくれるんです
だから犬も猫も仕事をしていますよ
ライオンも仕事をしています
鳥たちも動物もみんな仕事をしています
肉体を持ってるんだから
仕事をして この肉体にかける部分はスーッと入れて入れて入れても
一回入れてはそれで済むわけじゃないんです
全て無常だから 変化するんだから
入れても入れても入れても
またまた入れて入れていかなくちゃいけないんです
業だけではダメで 働く羽目になるんです
肉体を持っちゃうと そういうわけで
仕事をしなくちゃいけないということになるんです
随分単純だと思いますけど
話は そういうわけで 逆に仕事をしないのは悪行ですよ
体を持つなら仕事をするべきという法則です
体を持ってるんだったら仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
わがままで怠けて仕事をしないと勝手に決めても
それは悪行になって苦しみを作り出すんです
人間に勝手に私は仕事をしませんよとそう決めることはできません
動物も同じ 私は狩りをしませんよと決めたら
誰かが狩りをして獲物を持ってくるわけじゃないんです
例えばちっちゃい小さい時
雛とかね 生まれたら それで雛の業があるんですよ
親鳥から餌をもらうと
親鳥は全然物事考えてなんともないんでしょうね
考えるってことは人間がやってる仕事だから
でも随分大事に育てるでしょ
敵から守ってあげて あれが業なんですよ
それでその時期消えちゃうと
親鳥は追い出すんです
出して忘れちゃいます
自分の子供っていうことをさえ
巣立ちしてもうすぐ忘れるんです
だから我々飼ってるペットにも何か仕事をさせると
ペットの方が幸せになるんですよ
仕事をしているんだから
ただ餌あげただけではね
あんまり良くないんです
だからいろいろ芸を教えたり
いろんなことをしたりすると
頭の悪い犬とか勉強も理解しないんですけど
でもできるようになるとお互い楽しいんですよ
輪廻転生する限り 仕事は煩わしいと言っている場合ではありません
我々は輪廻転生しているんだから
肉体を持ったり あっちこっち転生するんだからね
仕事はなんか煩わしいとかね
今皆様がなさっている仕事
すごく煩わしくてストレス溜まるんだったらね
もう期待してください
それは無限大に続くんです
生まれたなら仕事は義務であって責任です
それから稼ぎと仕事って同じものですかと
同じではありません 微妙に違います
生まれた恵まれた環境なら
稼ぎは人生の中期だけやるものです
例えば 我々は恵まれた環境で生まれたならば
人生の中期で まあ二十歳ぐらいからとか
まあ仕事をすればいい
稼ぎすればいいんです
貧しい環境なら子供も老人も稼ぐんですよ
ものは無いんですよ だからちっちゃな子供でも学校に行くんじゃなくて
ちょっと歩けて なんとか手足もうちょっと力がついてくると
もう何かしで仕事するんですよ
年取っても もうもう私は体弱いとかね
言っていられる場合じゃないんですよ
何か仕事しなくちゃいけないんですね
それ その仕事とは稼ぎですね
だから稼ぎの場合はそういういろいろ差があるんですよ
仕事は一生やるんです
生まれてから死ぬまでやるんです
赤ちゃんも仕事はしますよ
稼ぎはしません 仕事は生きている上で
その時その時 その その時期必ず行わなくてはならない行為です
仕事を言えば 例えば四年
年は四歳ぐらいになったら
もう学問にしなくいけないんですよ
人間なら そういうことで
人間にはその時その時
どうしても避けられない
必ずしもやらなくちゃいけないということをする
それが仕事 文字通りの
だから仕事というのはworkという風に訳すれば
稼ぎというのはearnなんですね Work
とearnというのは 2つなんです
区別した方がいいんですよ
仕事は一生やる 稼ぎは人生の中で一部の時間だけでやるんです
それから稼ぎの世界 人には衣食住薬
これ四具というんですね
必要ですよ 人間は余計に快楽も欲しがるんですね
あの四つだけで十分なんですけど
人間はまた快楽も欲しがるんです
それらは働いて稼がなくてはならないんです
外から必要なものだからね
これなんでよ この快楽
余計と言ったんでしょうかというと
この四苦ぐらいだったらいとも簡単に手に入るでしょ
四苦ならベースにも一日稼いでいたら
もう 1週間ぐらいでも 2週間でも大丈夫というふうなこともあるし
でも快楽というもの これ余計
それが入っちゃうとお金がいくらあっても足らないんですよ
豪華な服を買いたいとかね
ブランドのカバンが欲しいとかね
ダイヤがついてるもうジュエリーやとかもうね
リングとか買いたいとかね
豪華な料理を食べる友達とパーティーをやりながら遊びたいとか思うと
それ快楽世界 別にそんなものなくても生きていられますよ
カバンはブランド品でないと死んだ人は一人もいないでしょうに
それ余計なことだから
仕事暇がないんです ずっと仕事してるんです
しかし 働き対収入の割合は業によって定めています
誰でも同じ量の働きに同じ量の収入は得られませんよ
どれぐらい働けばどれぐらい収入になるのかという割り当てがあるんですよ
それによって収入が決めるんですよ
これがわからないんですよ
業のことだから  1対1か2対1か1対2かわからない
少々の仕事をして大量の収入を得る人々いるでしょうに
その場合  1対4とか5とか 6とかなってますよ
必死で仕事をするんですけど
やっと間に合っている人々もいるでしょうに
その場合は 3対1とかね
業は働きは 3 で 収入は 1 とかね
その割り当ては死ぬまで変わらないんです
割合は 人間は余計に快楽
贅沢を欲しがるから 他の生命より必死で大量の仕事をしなくてはならないんですよ
人間は他の犬 動物よりは必死で仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
これは人間 余計に快楽いらん贅沢を求めるからなんですよ
いらんだから自己破壊するんですよ
必要な贅沢だったら贅沢とも言えないんですよ
必要な快楽ならもう快楽と言えないんですよ
いらんもの 必要でもないものを欲しがるでしょ
だったらその分むちゃな仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
現代 我々置かれている状態はそういう状態なんです
簡単に生きていられるのに
大変ですよ 生きることは
忙しいのは自分のせいですから
欲や怒りがある限り 必需品の量が増えるので
仕事をする以外暇はありません
欲が多いんだからね その分仕事をする羽目になるんです
怒りも同じですよ 負けたくはないとかね
それは業のせいではありません
業はそんな悪いことをしないんですよ
業は多いですからね 私たちがそのそれより感情
欲を作って 必要でないものも期待する
小欲地則であるならば
人生はとても楽しい 楽です
ものすごい楽なんです
人間の生まれは善業の結果です
人間に生まれたのは善業の結果ですよ
だから我々は本来ならものすごく穏やかで
ものすごく楽しく ものすごく豊かで
気楽にのんびり生きていられる生命ですよ
ほとんど神々とそれほど変わりがないんです
仏教から見れば 神々と違うところはもうもう年を取る
病気になる それから料理などは作って食べなくちゃいけない
ただそれだけ 他は全部神々と同じなんですが
今はね 人間の生命は何やというと
神々に近いどころか ほとんど餓鬼に近い地獄に近いところの生き方でしょう
これは業のせいじゃないんです
それは人間の余計な煩悩のせいなんです
心の汚れ 汚れというのは
根拠のない感情 欲望 見栄
他人に打ち勝つ気持ちなどですね
いっぱいありますね 煩悩は
善業の働きを妨げている
そこで私たちは良い合意をして生まれてるんだけど
この働かなくなっちゃうんですよ
コンピューターでいえば
何か入れたプログラムがおかしくて引っかかっちゃう
何かウイルスが入ったりして
コンピューターウイルスとかおかしくなっている
そういうことで 私たちは本当は幸福なんですけど
それがもう機能できなくなって壊れてしまっているんです
時々仕事は嫌になって
このような気持ちにもなってしまう
例えば 何のために働くのかという疑問なんですね
だから時々仕事をものすごい嫌になるんですよ
収入は足らないか 人間関係は悪いか
才能はないか 才能は生かせないか
財産を使う道はないか
いろいろ原因があるんですよ
お金があるんだけど 使う道がない
しかし 会社の社長だからもう仕事に行かなくちゃいけない
金はいくらでもあるんだけど
社長だったらもう暇がないんですね
嫌になるんですね もうなんでこんな朝早く起きて夜遅くまであれいろいろ会議やったり
いろんなところに走ったりしてて
ということは あるいは才能が生かせない
これ嫌になるんですよ
それはいろんなことで
仕事をしてもしても収入がない場合はね
もうやりたい気持ち消えちゃいますよ
本来の人生は稼ぐだけの生き方ではないから
もう一つ原因がありますよ
本来の人間の命っていうのは
稼ぐだけで死ねという生き方じゃないんですよ
一部の時間だけ稼いだらいいんですよ
我々は幸福に生きられる運命で生まれてるんですよ
だからそんなにたくさん稼がなくてもいいんです
人生の一部だけ これ忘れているんだから
だから金儲けだけをしている時
虚しさと衝突することもあります
もう仕事ばっかりやっていると
時々なんかえらい虚しさ
何やってるんですかと
一体全体私は何やと 衝突するんですよ
それは道から外れてるんだからなんです
適当な量稼いでいればそうなりませんよ
正しく生きていれば 地雷を踏んでよ
小判の雨が降っても人の欲は満たせないってのはブッダの言葉なんです
ナカハーパナワッセルティッティカーミースウィッジェットという人間は必需品を揃う主義ではなく
これが正しい主義なんですよ
ではなく 欲を満たす主義で生きているので
欲だけではなく 国もリミットがないんですよ
ちょっと文章はちょこっとややこしくなってますけど
まずお釈迦様の論理を考えると
それはすごい親切な言葉なんですよ
小判の雨が降っても あなたの欲望は満たせませんよと
もっと欲しがるんだから
欲望を捨てろって意味なんですよ
苦しいんだよと それで仕事はしなくちゃいけない
仏教から見ると必需必需品
必需品そろってもらわないととんでもないことになりますよ
ご飯は必要ですし 服は必要でしょうし
家が必要でしょうし それは必要ですよ
その分だけ仕事をすればいいんです
必需品を揃えますよと
ちゃんと電気代ガス代払いますよと
自分で 住民税もちゃんと住民税と
なんて言いますか 国民のなんとか
なんて言いますか みんな払わなくちゃいけない
なんて言いますかね 国民年金とかね
そういうのはちゃんと自分で払いますよとかね
それぐらいだったら何のこともないんだけど
人間は欲を満たすために仕事をするんですよ
ものすごい危なくて ものすごい邪見で邪道でキリがないんです
だからむちゃくちゃなんです
人間の人生は そんないくら仕事したっても欲は満たせませんよ
だから仕事をすればするほど苦しみ
苦しみ 苦しみばっかり
時々金儲けばっかりしていると
家族はバラバラで 子供が不良になったりして
殺人まで犯したりする
それって明らかに不幸でしょ
欲を満たせたんだからなんですよ
幸福に気楽に生きていられる運命なのに
人は地雷を踏んでるんです
欲を満たすということ
もうどうにもならない
だから今でも欲を満たす主義を必需品を揃うという主義に入れ替えれば
もう地雷はないんです
すごく楽しく生きていられるんです
それで結果 景気が悪い仕事はない
もう破産 倒産 収入は足らない
自然破壊 資源は足らない
競争に負ける 仕事はきつい
不正違反行為など あらゆるもの世の中にあるでしょ
何ですかね それが なんで人間だけ地球を破壊してるんですかね
人間の数っていうのはすごい少ないでしょうね
動物と比べてみると 動物は自然は微妙にでも破壊しない
ものすごく調和している
それにしたら人間は 生きることで日々自然を破壊するんです
なんででしょうかね 欲を満たすんだからなんですよ
必需品だけもらうと自然破壊にはなりません
うまくバランス調和取れるんですよ
なんで破産倒産があるんですかね
欲を満たすんだからなんです
それから仕事のストレス
能力は向上しないことも
仕事環境が悪くなるのも
やる気が失うことも 地雷を踏んでるせいなのです
みんな言ってる文句でしょうにね
ストレス溜まるわ 能力はなかなか開発できない
自分の仕事環境はすごく悪いんだと
人間関係とかね 欲を満たすことの結果なんです
地雷を踏んでいる